we're not playing with y'all vehicle
cello
welcome to the UK and we are joined by
Leo me and you sir thank you for having
me
the angel of the desert is with me and
you love the night and we're gonna talk
festivals and your alternative festival
guy are you could show the ready what do
you think she's ready that jackets on me
she's ready now okay so what do you
think is the difference between UK
festivals and US festivals
okay so UK festivals they're really as
we would say sketchy I would say it's
not even a word each other so clean have
that really cool ferris wheel like it's
very like Instagram ready so that to me
about the biggest difference it's
swimming in poo and lots of it a bit you
heard it here first
now pitch the scene babe you're in a 10
you've only got two minutes to get ready
okay I'll get my quick drag as reported
say the first thing that I would do is
browse then highlight that's all I would
if I was doing a very quick makeup yeah
and obviously I'm gonna complete my look
with a little bit Turia secret push-up
bra she is pushing up the public of
Coachella babe they are not ready do you
do that every time you put on the vs
prize go I do is that what happened it
gives me like a very very boom how you
come for an Instagram moment on that
night now obviously like you've got to
be prepared with the Footwear when it
comes to a festival right you do luckily
for us we're on the California desert
the only thing we're dealing with is the
wind yeah but what is your ultimate
Footwear fail at a festival would you
say so I was like going for a walk at
night trying to be on a new area
definitely like just looked over my
shoulder took a step steps in
extreme diarrhea okay we see not real
diarrhea but you know what I mean
I look to my phone I was just like I'm
ready to go home now however luckily for
us we are getting our fluff on babes
aren't we having some fluff on the first
one thing that I love about others just
how comfortable they are but still doing
cute cute pop of color yeah even if
feminine people it's chic keeping it
furry but also getting a little breeze
between my toes next up on the road trip
here we come
alright and now we're joined by slick
words yes I'm gonna give you a situation
right now you're in the ten have you
been in a tent a tent new thing like you
pitching your campaign or doesn't happen
okay so you never put your time hello
fort associates
proper pillows
Laurel County League turn on the light
that was your campaign yeah
but the key question is if you have two
minutes to get ready in your imaginary
ten she's never been in what would you
do to get your game face on for each
other in two minutes
how would you do it yeah I just rolled
out a bit dirt bag shape
watch the pits room you might have to
shave
make sure nobody knows you're very low
maintenance babe I mean let's not say
if I get lucky at Coachella this weekend
let's pray and I had to try and start
him out the tenth walk of shame have a
pudding the walk of shame how I style it
out so what do you do is you can do some
Erykah Badu [ __ ] you poke a hole at the
bottom for the changes and lower you
thought I [ __ ] on your head like a hat
it's you like running no you walk you
because you got a VLC Oh Lady Gaga [ __ ]
this is us again you fill me can we not
plan which our vehicle cello so we gotta
go though we have made it on a road trip
all the way to Palm Springs and I'm
joined by one of the new Queens of music
huh how are you yeah feelin it oh yeah
I'm here like I said you brought me to
the Coachella vibes I needed your energy
you brought me here today yes I'm
staying in the pocket that's the model
for today that's we're staying in the
pocket which has come from your dance
routine hasn't it because we were just
saying like you'll go to like dance
routine it's like you're just shoulders
yeah obviously people get to the point
of the festival when they're like Dave
3m right and you're performing on day
for your Coachella yes so you're gonna
have to like save your vibe for that I
do yeah do you have to like take it easy
so would you say you basically just
can't go in too heavy to quit no no and
you miss you favor on us you don't want
to do that I don't even know what I'm
gonna do when I see you on the station
I'll be like well but your Energy's
great - I'm just so it's so great to see
someone who's like you know you've
worked so hard to get to this stage and
now you're on patella it's been a year
you would just guess appearing last year
what do you think the person who was
performing last year with us said to the
person here today so I would just say
you got this he's all about elevation
that's what I continue to say to myself
yeah yeah you got this
it's about elevation stay in that pocket
guys stay in that pocket
[Music]